Life, as anyone will tell you, is not fair.
But how important is fairness?
Hello everyone, Crystal here for DNews.
Let’s play a game, I’m given $100 and
I can choose to offer to give some, or none,
to you. If you accept my offer, we both get
to keep the money, but if you don’t, we
both get nothing. How much of the 100 would
I have to offer you before you’d accept?
$20?
40?
How would you feel if I offered you $3?
You’d probably leave us both with nothing
just to spite me for being greedy. Right?
This set up is called an Ultimatum Game, and
it is used by behavioral scientists to study
the construct of “fairness”. In human
adults, any offer lower than 20% of the total
is usually rejected and researchers conclude
that this stems from a common expectation
of “fairness”. But how do we decide what’s
“fair”?
Our idea of fair changes over time. For children
younger than school age, what is fair is usually
what is equal. (When my sister was little,
she could never understand why I would get
more of something because I was older) but
as we develop, our sense of fairness shifts
to become rooted in merit based reasoning,
that’s why in adults it is more common for
higher value individuals be the most rewarded,
and researchers at MIT and the University
of Rochester recently proposed that this shift
correlates to when we learn to count.
These researchers studied 70 children between
the ages of 3 and 12 that belonged to the
Tsimane' tribe in the Amazon. Each child was
shown two drawings of identical children.
Then they were told that the children in the
drawings were sent to pick bananas, one child
had worked very hard and brought back 18 bananas,
and the other picked only 4. The researchers
then gave the participant children an even
number of paper cookies and asked them to
distribute the cookies as a reward to the
banana pickers. Children that could count,
distributed more reward cookies to the successful
banana picker instead of distributing cookies
evenly between the two.
These results were interesting because Tsimane’
children learn to count at varying ages, and
they saw that how these children bestowed
a reward and did not correlate with age as
in previous studies. The researchers propose
that children may understand the concept of
rewarding greater efforts before they learn
to count, but they can't accurately translate
that understanding into an appropriate distribution
because they can’t yet represent quantity
with numeric values.
So is “fair” ever “equal”?
Ideas of “fair” and equal are present,
not just in humans, but in primates too. A
now famous study done in monkeys by Sarah
Brosnan and Frans de Waal shows that when
two monkeys, in full view of each other, are
asked to perform an identical task but receive
unequal rewards the monkey who receives the
lowest reward reacts strongly and violently
to the inequality as, well, any one of us
would!
So what does this intrinsic understanding
of equality mean in our unequal society?
Economists Michael Norton and Dan Ariely published
results of an experimental survey in 2011
that shows Americans greatly underestimate
the level of inequality extant in our own
society and when asked, we even say we would
like a much more equal distribution of societal
wealth than both what we have and what we
think we have.
However, when Norton and Ariely asked their
experimental subjects to design the wealth
distribution of a society that the subjects
would be willing to enter at any hierarchical
level, the participants did *not* create a
society that was mathematically equal across
all class designations. Implying, that even
when tasked with creating a fair and equal
social structure, we’d still like the possibility
of getting just a little bit more than everyone
else.
Sometimes, life just isn't fair. one place
where unfairness runs wild is in sports!
Learn why subconscious bias can interfere
with important calls, in this video.
What do you think is more important?
Fairness or equality?
Subscribe to DNews and let us know in the
comments down below. Thanks for watching!
What do you think is more important?
Fair or equal?
let us know in the comments down below and
keep coming back to testube.com for more science,
every day of the week.
What is more important to you?
fairness or equality? we have all kinds of
ways you can let us know. You can find us
on Facebook as Discovery News and on Twitter
@DNews or come find me @PolycrystalhD